comment ça va allô je m'appelle Isabelle
chapardeau je suis Inouk de
j'ai aussi grandi avec mon papa à cette
cire au Québec je suis vraiment excitée
de faire ses vidéos là avec vous je vais
être avec vous à chaque deux semaines je
vais vous amener avec moi dans ma
culture amener certains sujets qui
m'intéressent par rapport aux
autochtones peut-être même des
événements je suis vraiment contente
parce que aussi j'ai l'impression qu'il
manque d'informations sur les Inuits en
français donc je vais pouvoir vous
amener avec moi ce qui est vraiment cool
aussi c'est que je suis dans l'éducation
en ce moment je travaille à Ottawa dans
une organisation inouïe c'est super
excitant ce travail là pour moi ça
m'enrichit énormément mais j'ai aussi
accès à plusieurs ressources à plusieurs
personnes la jeunesse des personnes
âgées de l'or autochtone de leur Inuit
peut-être qu'on voit pas souvent on
n'est pas folle entouré de leur Inuit
des fois si on ne connaît pas de Inuit
autour de nous donc moi je suis vraiment
reconnaissante de pouvoir faire ça je
voulais aussi finir en vous expliquer le
nom de ces vidéos de ces chroniques-là
que je vais partager avec vous ça
s'appelle où le MI ou le MI la
traduction c'est aujourd'hui simplement
pour moi aujourd'hui c'est l'entre-deux
ce qui fait du sens entre le passé et le
futur j'aime vraiment ça aussi me dire
que je suis présente aujourd'hui avec
vous je suis en vie des fois c'est pas
facile avec les trucs autochton
qu'est-ce qui se passe les enjeux mais
je suis super heureuse de pouvoir être
présente aujourd'hui avec vous merci
beaucoup d'accord mec avec tout pour
aujourd'hui c'est une petite vidéo de
présentation je suis super heureuse on
se voit bientôt bye à la prochaine